this episode of the minimalists is 100%
advertisement free so if you'd like to
help support the podcast you can always
visit the minimalists comm / donate
enjoy the show every little thing you
think that's mean every little thing you
think that you need every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh I bet
that you'll be fine without me
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalists podcast where we talk about
living a meaningful life with less less
stuff less stress less debt and
discontent and overwhelm and anxiety and
a whole lot more meaning I'm Joshua
fields Millburn and in a minute you'll
hear from Ryan Nicodemus as well this is
another special quicky episode of the
minimalists although it's a fairly long
quickie episode but it's just a bit
different from our traditional episodes
we wanted to get this one out to you
today because it is a Tuesday that it is
posting and that's why the title of this
episode which is episode number six by
the way the title of this episode is
Tuesdays
you see for the last couple months Ryan
and I have had a ton of fun doing
something called Tuesdays with the
minimalists where basically we get on to
Twitter and periscope for about an hour
a little less than an hour and just
answer a bunch of random questions from
people live in a live setting is very
informal it's very impromptu you can
pretty much ask whatever you want and we
try to answer those questions to the
best of our ability so it's more like
questions and attempted answers because
you know what my favorite pedagogical
technique is if I don't know the answer
to your question I'll just I'll still
answer it but I'll just provide a
different answer I'll answer a different
question and and so you can ask whatever
you want on Tuesdays with us and we
wanted to kind of give you a sample of
that a few
weeks ago we recorded one of our
episodes of tuesdays with the
minimalists and really enjoyed it had a
lot of great questions a lot of great
interactions so today's broadcast is a
as a rebroadcast of that if you missed
it or if you just wanted a refresher the
thing about periscope is that those
videos delete after 24 hours which I
really like the ephemeral nature of that
but we wanted to save one is in sort of
a time capsule form and share it here on
the podcast if you want to join us on
future Tuesdays I'm pretty sure we'll be
doing it for a while at least until our
documentary comes out it's every Tuesday
at 7 p.m. Eastern on Twitter and
periscope you can just find us over
there all the details by the way are on
our blog over at the minimalists dot-com
slash Tuesday's oh and by the way
speaking of our documentary we have a
tour we're going to 14 different cities
with our documentary in May and we'd
love to see you there so all the details
are at the minimalists com slashed or
you can also help bring the documentary
to your city it's screening and hundreds
of cities at this point but you can you
can find a screening and get your
tickets or you can request a screen
bring the documentary to your city as
well just go to minimalism film.com
slash watch or if you just go to
minimalism film calm click on see the
film all the details are there and if
you are outside of the United States
don't worry we are planning a theatrical
release in Canada and Australia we're
also working on overseas distribution
for elsewhere so stay tuned for that and
of course wherever we don't go we'll
have a worldwide online release of the
film after the theatrical run one last
quick update on February 7th 2016 I'm
doing a one-day or a two-hour online
workshop writing workshop for my how to
write better class you can get all the
details on that over at how to write
better dot-org I wanted to make that
free but I had to end up charging 20
bucks so we could pay for the webinar
software and I also want to make sure
we paid my adjunct professor Sean
Halleck but if you can't afford the 20
bucks don't worry you can get a one-day
scholarship you can just email Sean at
how to write better org and he can try
to set you up with a one-day scholarship
if you have questions for future
episodes of the podcast call us at 4:06
2 1 9 7 8 3 9 we have a bunch of
questions we're going to be answering in
the upcoming weeks or you can ask us a
question on facebook instagram or
twitter using the hashtag ask the
minimalists that's all I got right now I
really hope you enjoy this broadcast of
Tuesdays with the minimalists enjoy
welcome to Tuesday with the minimalists
we are just as excited to be here what
kind of questions you guys have we you
know usually we just kind of like rattle
off questions from Twitter and from
Instagram which we can still do but uh
we kind of want to answer some live
questions uh anything y'all wanna you
want to know you want to know whether
Josh wears boxers or briefs trick
question he doesn't wear underwear
minimalism hahahaha all right I love the
podcast how are you guys like it loving
us so far we just came from we recorded
our third episode this one's about
children yes man I I became sort of a
parent by proxy last year my partner
Rebecca Becks she has a two and a half
year old daughter and I am learning so
much and we're able to sort of share our
lessons from that can I be a minimalist
about but still have options no you
can't have any out nope next question
now of course you can I mean then it was
about it's about finding the the it's
about finding the important options
absolutely you know it's funny someone
on one of a periscope said something
like oh these guys are minimalist they
didn't give up anything important and I
would agree with that person on the
latter point that no we did not give up
anything important and that's exactly
what minimalism is it's about curating
your life and having a very well edited
life so yeah I would say that minimalism
gives you way more options that's all a
question to pop up or what
better off way better options yeah amen
yeah absolutely I saw a question to pop
up about family if you go to the
minimalists com forward slash family
there's a really good essay that we
wrote there speaking to that question of
what do I do if my family doesn't want
to take on these minimalist principles
or they like to hoard stuff there's some
really good advice there yeah we
interviewed a bunch of minimalist
families for our documentary too that
really stand out to me are Joshua Becker
and Leo Bob alte we have some resources
for them if you go to the minimalists
comm slash children there's a great book
there and also a great essay Leo has six
kids his wife Eva have six kids and so
they live as a minimalist family in the
city it's pretty awesome
how do pets fit in the minimalist
lifestyle well you can't have any pets
as a minimalist in fact we're against
all fun and all love no of course
whatever man having have a pet if a pet
brings you joy and you and you love
having that companion then of course
there's nothing wrong with with having a
pet that's that's what's cool about
minimalism there are no rules it's not
like you can or cannot have anything
it's really about curating a life for
yourself so if a pet fits into that and
the pet food and the chew toy you know
maybe you only get him one chew toy I
don't know that's what I did with my cat
after the packing party I remember
pulling out like one toy for him and he
actually said this is what's kind of
funny he actually played with that one
toy that I brought out a lot and because
I didn't have a lot of other toys
scattered around he actually kept track
of that one whereas before when I had
you know million hair barrettes or not
hair barrettes hair ties or that my
girlfriend gave me two for him to play
with or a little cat balls and jingling
cat toys he did a really good job of
throwing those in places I would never
see so it was funny when I gave him one
toy how well he kept track of everything
about pets are minimalist by Nature
the human-beings are - we've we've just
gotten confused over the last couple of
centuries I saw a question about DVDs
what do you think about huge DVD
collections
I think they suck how do we get why
would we have a DVD collection but were
you going to watch him keep watching the
same movies over and over and over I
mean this is what I had to say to myself
Ryan Murray used to come over to my
house when I was back in the corporate
world I had this wall of DVDs now by the
way the word collection if you look it
up in a thesaurus the Oxford English
dictionary's thesaurus the synonym for
collection is hoard when I think of or
word i think of hoarding so for
collecting often we are hoarding and so
you have to keep that in mind plus by
the way technology has enabled us to we
don't have to own a thousand DVDs we
have hundreds of thousands of movies at
our fingertips with the internet and a
bunch of different subscription based
services and YouTube etc yeah I mean if
DVDs are your thing you know they truly
serve a purpose do they bring you joy
yeah all right if you love the DVDs
great I would say the same person who
has a record collection it's I mean I
personally I can't tell the difference
in sound quality from a record and it's
an mp3 or mp4 some people can I guess
and that's great but for me those
substitutes work DVDs what's that amen
it's my computer I don't actually I
don't even own a DVD player yeah it's
can one find ways to integrate passions
in everyday life without making a leap
of faith yeah I think I think acting on
faith alone is usually a bad decision I
think the key is finding something
you're passionate about not passions but
passion and cultivate it into something
that that's meaningful don't mistake
excitement for passion though too often
we say I'm really excited about this
idea and we confuse it for being
passionate about it but the problem is
when it gets hard we abandon that idea
we can't abandon the idea we have to be
willing to stick with it through the
difficult times the mundane the tedious
times the drudgery we have to Drudge
through the drudgery I feel like we're
repeating the conversation we had this
morning when I was with you and I was
writing and you were talking me into
drudging through the drudgery
yeah we met this morning to go through
Ryan's working on on the book right now
has been for a while and that's nothing
not feeling it like man I want to stop
right now I just I need to take care of
these other things I've got I've got a I
just can't write right now what did you
say well if we were at it like this
coffee shop and I said what if you were
working behind the counter here or think
back to the corporate world we used to
manage these these retail stores if you
were on the sales floor back back in the
day you couldn't just say I'm just
really not feeling this right now I've
got line of customers out the door but
I'm not feeling I think I'm gonna go
work on something else no you have to
treat your passions like your job you
have to be committed to you as we
willing to put in the work because if
you don't put in the work you're never
going to get the real payoff yes there
are other things that are easier passive
tasks are easier taking care of what's
urgent in the moment can be easier but
just because something seems urgent
doesn't mean that it's necessarily
important in fact urgency is often the
enemy of meaning and so keep that in
mind when you're working on something
that is truly important to you other
things might seem urgent but they may
not be as important what other questions
you have described the minimalist diet
you can read my exact diet ingredient by
ingredient at the minimalists comm slash
diet I have a relatively simple diet I
used to work weigh about 80 pounds more
than I weigh now and I needed to
simplify my my life when it came to diet
and exercise so you can see both there
at our website I'm a teacher and a
student so my life often feels like
paper laden mess thoughts yeah I have a
scanning party go to the minimalists
comm slash scanning this works
especially with photos I know I did with
photos but also with important documents
tax records etc you can scan all that
stuff and it does a few things with
documents it makes it searchable so you
no longer have to deal with with I've
got this file over here this file in the
attic no you can have it all scan and if
you don't feel like scanning all
yourself you can go to $1.00 scan comm
and they have
a bunch of a bunch of resources where
you can send them your photos or
documents they'll scan it for you upload
it and they actually get rid of the
stuff for ya incinerator so you can't
get this stuff back it's a pretty cool
deal where are you scared when you left
your day job well I got laid off kind of
strategically I guess but I will say
that I I knew it was coming I knew it
was coming when ice at my office are I'm
sorry I said my boss down in my office
and I said hey I want to talk about if I
ever leave the company who are you gonna
replace me with and he kind of looked at
me he's like you don't even thought
about that because things are going
pretty well you have things running
pretty smoothly I don't know if I would
need to replace you and I'm like huh
that's an interesting thought huh and
next thing you know next month I get a
text you know meet me in room 202 Donald
no the Norwood building right where Josh
and I both have laid off many people
before I knew what was coming but I
prepared up to that point so a year
before that I had started saving money I
started paring down on my debt and that
is really what helped me to get over
that fear of of losing that day job so
when I finally did get laid off I was at
a point where I had dramatically reduced
my debt I could have survived uh on a on
a baristas salary essentially I had
moved into an apartment that was 400
bucks a month I got rid of my car
payment I got rid of my condo payment um
literally got down to where I could live
off of you know twenty five thousand
thirty thousand dollars a year easily
and and that is really what helped me to
get over that fear it's it's funny
because it's such you know a simple
advice to say well you know just form a
plan before you before you leave your
job implementing that plan sticking to
that plan drudging through the drudgery
with that plan that's the hard part but
the payoff is huge and you will it will
help to mitigate that fear if you want
to see our plan step by step by step to
get out of debt and really plan for
moving on you can go to it's an essay
called financial freedom it's a long one
but it is step by step and
very detailed the minimalists calm /
freedom and to answer your question was
I scared no I was more scared of staying
because I saw the guys who I aspired to
be like and as I got closer as I climbed
that corporate ladder I realized the
guys who I once wanted to be those guys
were [ __ ] miserable and if I worked
really hard for the next 15 to 20 years
I could be just as miserable as them
Josh what book would you recommend for
aspiring writers quite a few but I teach
a writing class called how to write
better you can go to how to write better
dot-org and find a bunch of free
resources there and I'm hosting a free
online seminar coming up pretty soon but
if I were to recommend one I recommend
grammatically correct by Anne Stillman
that's a great one yeah and so I would
start there and I've got a bunch of
other resources at how to write better
yeah grammatically correct that is one
of the like 10 books that I own still
most physical books I also don't say
maybe white like the Strunk & white yeah
the problem with that is a lot of the
rules they have in that book it's a
great start but the rules are a bit
antiquated and and some of them are sure
wrong like that they're their thoughts
on passive tense that they're just wrong
though they're examples of passive tense
writing aren't actual passive tense
writing example so they they do a poor
job in some areas I would start with
grammatically correct for sure and then
you're looking for what is called a
modern usage dictionary
I recommend Brian Gardner's modern usage
dictionary as well with a question come
up how do I involve myself with the
local minimalist communities if I don't
use Facebook yeah so so what they're
talking about is we have a hundred free
local meetup groups at minimalist org
that's in 8 different countries and
folks meet locally usually once a month
in their community surround themselves
with local open-minded people you don't
have to have Facebook to go to those
meet ups and that's the nice thing there
in-person meetups if you want to
interact with
people online we have found after
testing a bunch of different platforms
that Facebook is the easiest way for us
to have people communicate with each
other the other thing you could do and
we've actually had quite a few readers
do this is you can create your own
Facebook account just for minimalist org
yeah you can't interact with those
people yet you can totally you can
create it under even under your real
name and just block your profile and
don't make a public yeah and no one else
will know that you're on there yeah um a
lot of the groups are open so you can
just log on there and look at the date
if for some reason you come across the
closed group where it's requiring you to
make a Facebook profile you don't even
want to make that a that anonymous
Facebook profile feel free to send me an
email
it's Ryan at the minimalists dot-com and
I will tell you when there's a meet-up
in your local area I'd be happy to do
that for you so just send me an email
and I'll totally fill you in what other
questions do you have I saw a lot about
clothes talk about your cardigan now we
keep it simple you know it's funny I
literally have this like black t-shirt
and blue jean outfit and it's it's
because I really feel good in it and
it's the same outfit I wear every single
day I don't have to wake up and make a
million decisions on what I'm gonna wear
it don't have to look in the mirror and
see how it looks I don't have clothes
that are sitting in my closet with tags
on them that one day I might fit into I
I have simplified my wardrobe to that
extent and what I love about being an
adult is it's totally cool to wear the
same thing every day as long as you
don't stink you know you got to be
respectful of others but uh but no I I
have one outfit I love it um Josh has a
pretty standard outfit too
yeah you know someone said it do you
think it's harder for women I have a
good probably both not necessarily I
could tell you my partner
you know she certainly has has more
clothes than I do but she doesn't
struggle with clothes more than I do if
I struggled a lot more with clothes that
was one of my sort of vices my consumer
vices back in the corporate world
and man I had so many walk-in closets
full clothes yeah and it was
unbelievable
here's what I'll say no I don't think it
genders necessarily I think society puts
more pressure on women and thus we have
more advertisements that are geared
toward women's fashion
the average American sees 5000
advertisements day that's a million year
and I'm certain more the fashion
advertisements are about women than they
are about men so yes you're advertised
more to it but the good news is you you
can turn that off and you can choose to
be more deliberate here's the the rule
that I have I call it the 1990 rule have
I worn it in the last 90 days and will I
wear in the next 90 days if it's answer
is no to both of those then it's gotta
go it can't be in my closet and you can
attenuate that event if you want if you
want to say it's 30 days 30 days the
reason why is 90 90 that accounts for
all seasons you know we live in Montana
so in July it gets hot here but right
now it's January and it's freaking cold
so 90 90 accounts for 180 days to
accounts for all seasons yeah I saw a
question what do you guys get criticized
for the most be uh for being the
minimalists well I'll tell you when you
call yourselves the minimalists
everything becomes steeped in irony
there's not a very minimal amount of
people on this periscope right now we
don't sell a minimal amount of books
certainly everything we do is steeped in
irony but you know the end of the day
I've never heard any criticism that that
I've taken to heart usually it's just
someone kind of calling out something
ironic which like I said everything
becomes ironic when you call yourself a
minimalist let's talk about criticism
from it from and when people are
criticizing there's a such thing as
constructive criticism sure like I'm I
send an essay to Ryan and say tell me
what you think about these points and I
need your feedback that's constructive
criticism but when people are judging
you really the judgments are but a
mirror that reflect the insecurities of
the person who's doing the judging and
so it puts up a mirror and says really
if I'm criticizing you about X Y & Z I
mean
secur personally about XY and z yeah
yeah and someone is prophet good point
they said you find people who get
defensive when you bring up topics on
minimalism and yeah I mean just to Josh
this point of people judging themselves
when they're when there's really you
know criticizing us it is this fear of
oh wow here here's someone who is making
more deliberate decisions oh man they
don't have a TV man should I have a TV
did that it starts to make them ask
those questions to themselves and yeah
certainly people will get defensive on
the TV a side of things like I have a TV
I keep it in the closet I'll take it out
when me and my girlfriend one watch a
movie or something Josh doesn't have a
TV when he wants his watch TV he'll call
me up and come over to my house and
watch TV so yeah there is no again
there's no certain way to live a
minimalist life
it's a very individual thing and and
once I can kind of get that fruit to
most people that they usually get a lot
less defensive because they're not
looking at me like I'm judging them as
much as like oh here's a guy who's
sharing a recipe that works for him and
he's just trying to do just that share
something that is working for him
doesn't mean that I have to use every
single ingredient of that recipe but but
you know hopefully there's an ingredient
or two there that people can find value
in speaking of TV because I saw someone
mention it really quickly yeah it
doesn't doesn't mean there's anything
inherently wrong with TV and there may
be a day where I decide you know I think
a TV would add value to my life and I
decided to bring it back into my life I
would strongly urge people to get the TV
the hell out of your bedroom yeah the
bed is made for two things and neither
of what which includes channel surfing
and and so especially for guys here guys
this is directed at you your wife
significant other partner girlfriend
boyfriend whomever will be a lot happier
with you if you decide to get the the TV
out of the bedroom for a while no doubt
someone asked us if we had any survival
gear
we're not Preppers so there's some
things with a something with it can you
can a prepper still be a minimalist yeah
and I was like in order to be prepared
one doesn't need to be a prepper right
that is true um no we're not I mean
survival I mean I snowboard I have like
camping equipment and camping equipment
um that you know if I'm if I'm gonna go
off into the woods in Montana for a few
days um yes I certainly have that type
of gear but no that's that's about to
the extent I mean I have enough gear
where if I needed to go out somewhere
for 10 10 days 15 days I probably have
enough enough gear to last that but but
yet no but besides that nothing else are
you still happy with betterment yeah
absolutely I use use betterment from our
retirement I'm not happy with the stock
market last year I had the worst year
since 2008 but yeah I invest an index
fund that's what this person's talking
about if you want to see our retirement
plan and literally my retirement account
down to the dollar you can do that over
at the minimalists comm slash retire yes
we are not someone was like what do you
think about money we are not allergic to
money I mean money is is certainly a
tool that that you can use to do some
really cool things with you know luckily
that's kind of our opportunity cost now
I mean we're not solely focused on money
but but yeah we're certainly not
allergic to it either someone said the
market will get better yeah well I mean
over time if you invest in index funds
you're going to get a appreciable return
on that and you're investing for the
long haul I don't believe in trading
stocks or even buying stocks did you buy
a Powerball ticket sorry
waste yeah I mean it I I find there are
practical ways to invest your money and
so we've written pretty extensively
about how how we've done that over the
years yeah garden no I have not gardened
yet but my girlfriend has a green thumb
and like grew up her mom had her mom and
dad had like a seed companies
of gardening and she promised me the
spring she was gonna help me plant a
garden if you can't get a degree what
would you study the question who physics
a lot about this actually
um I really really love science and I
love math and if I had to go back to
school it would probably be for physics
or acting but I know I know personal
acting coaches who because again that's
another hobby that I have that I love um
I know personal acting coaches that I
could spend less money on and getting
better advice so so I probably want to
go to school for that but I would
consider that but physics for sure I
have definitely considered that what
about you have you consider going back
to school oh yeah
so yeah if I went back to school would
be it would be for a hobby it wouldn't
be for a living for sure um you're on
the someone said they're in the
corporate world how does that mesh with
minimalism you know what again there is
no perfect template to be a minimalist I
mean minimalist really someone said it
earlier about uh Africa how they
rephrase it but you can call it
deliberate ISM you can call it
simplicity essential is essential is
intentional ISM call or whatever you
want but at the end of the day you know
working in the corporate world if you're
happy if that aligns with your values
and beliefs because that's really what
minimalism is for me it's about it's
about curating my life creating enough
time enough space enough resources to
really stay in line with my long-term
values and beliefs so all of my
short-term actions I really tried to
keep in alignment with those long-term
values and beliefs so what I would say
is if your corporate job aligns with
your long-term values and beliefs great
congratulations you've found an awesome
corporate job and you're still
minimalist like I would say our our CPA
that we have that does our taxes I would
say he's a minimalist he works in the
corporate world he freaking loves
accounting the dude was passionate about
accounting death and I gotta tell you if
you pick an accountant like that's the
one you want the guy that's passionate
about it ya know but if you're
conflicted if you'll discontent that's
because your values don't align so your
long term values are on line with your
shorts or that term actions and if
that's the case you've got to get the
[ __ ] out of there
they didn't have a plan to do it doesn't
mean well you need to quit your job and
start a blog no you have to figure out a
plan and to get there again I'd
recommend the minimalists comm slash
freedom
there's also another essay in there
called a1 need like and you'll be able
to find a link to that and there I think
it's the minimalists comm slash want do
you guys support a zero-waste or what do
you think no I don't support a
zero-waste
I believe in consuming considerably less
and producing considerably less waste
I think it's unrealistic to to think
that people will go out of their way to
produce zero waste and I don't think our
problem is binary it's not zero waste or
always it's about radically reducing our
consumption so that we can produce less
waste in the process time management
suggestions for working on multiple
projects don't work on multiple projects
will be my first suggestion you are what
you focus on and so I think it's one of
the common misconception we think you
know I'm passionate about five things so
allocate now we're here our here our
here our here I noticed this in the
blogging world we first started we had
friends were like yeah I've got a
barefoot running blog and a minimalism
blog and a tea-drinking blog and here's
my tumblr page and it's like well wait a
minute why don't you focus on one thing
and really cultivate that passion and a
book I would recommend to you is a book
by Cal Newport it's called so good they
can't ignore you and we did an interview
with him over at the minimalists comm
slash Cal and he thinks that follow your
passion is shitty advice and I agree
with them the better advice is cultivate
your passion we had a nice conversation
over there at the minimalists comm slash
Cal you can check that out yes and
someone asked about starting a website
we actually have two essays that we
wrote the minimalist com4 slash blog and
the minimalists com4 slash blogging two
really good articles on how to you know
start a blog sort of website if that's
what you're looking to do I saw that
part of there are those are step by step
recipe because we have we kept getting
so many emails people say hey I really
like what you're doing I like to wait
looks or whatever how do you get people
to read your subject and we were tired
of like answering these these questions
on Twitter email or whatever over and
over and over so we just wrote a
step-by-step instruction of how we did a
person it's our recipe and you can tweet
out the ingredients that work for you
and and hopefully create your own recipe
the minimalists comm slash blog yeah I
saw someone asks where they could go to
find a thanks to find a good tips on
their wardrobe um the best thing I can
think of is a project 3 3 3 that's
Courtney Carver and the minimum calm and
the minimalists calm that's 90 spelled
out by the way and the Midwest's calm
slash clothes that one's called the
favorite clothes of a minimalist yeah
how do in friendships that are adding
value yeah absolutely so there's a essay
on our side I wrote a letter to all of
my fake friends from yesteryear it's
called goodbye fake friends it's the
minimalists calm slash fake and one of
the principles I love my life by and
best advice ever got was from my friend
Jamar who's still a good friend he said
you can't change the people around you
but you can change the people around you
and I'll let you run that back and think
it through basically you can't fix the
people in your life you can try to help
them as much as you can but don't go
trying to fix people and said surround
yourself with people or supportive
like-minded similar values similar
desires they may be radically different
people if you look at me and you look at
Ryan totally different personalities you
look at this on the myers-briggs we are
exact opposites literally and we have
different personalities we even have
different beliefs but we have similar
values we have many similar interests
different interests as well sure and and
similar desires then today we both want
to contribute to the world we both want
to grow in fact that's one of the
reasons we started doing the podcast now
we're we don't think we're very good at
it
we're very good at this either but it
allows us to grow by having these
conversations with you so thank you for
giving us the opportunity to do it
what are your myers-briggs I mean I'm an
EF ENFP that was close I'm gonna die in
TJ I in SJ and so yeah pretty close
there for those of you don't know the
myers-briggs is you can go to the
minimalists comm slash alone and you can
learn about my a long time I spent about
90% my time alone by the way here's the
thing INTJs are the most rare but
everyone who's an IV j because they're
so analytical knows they're freaking
INTJ although my thank you to Shawn
Harding he's our podcast producer he
wears many hats here at the minimalist
he's the guy who is typing up all of
these these links so that you have
access visual access to seeing these
links why do we love black coffee well
I'll tell you why I love black coffee is
because once I had really really good
coffee um that that did it for me I I
didn't want to put cream and sugar in it
I wanted to appreciate the taste now I
will say I was already raised from a
very young age to drink black coffee
like my dad would always say son if
you're gonna put cream and sugar in
there just drink hot chocolate so I
always drink black coffee but I did
switch to sugar and cream as I got older
to make it easier to go down but once I
had really really good coffee it turns
out you don't need that stuff to to make
the coffee go down while it coffee like
anything else like beer any wine
whatever it is an acquired taste I would
say yes um but but yeah I mean I much
would much rather drink black coffee
than creamy sugar I put cream and sugar
in my coffee this morning but because it
was kind of it wasn't that good of
coffee so I did have to put something in
developer go down but definitely prefer
black coffee for sure we wrote an essay
called life is an acquired taste you can
go to the minimalists comm slash coffee
and it is a metaphor I think black
coffee is a metaphor for the rest of our
lives as well if you simplify you can
enjoy it must more much more and that's
that's what I do with my coffee now I
actually enjoy the coffee much more
because
have a watered down with milk and
Splenda and all these other things yeah
any advice on getting rid of family
heirlooms yeah I mean sentimental items
is the most difficult so don't start
there when I was getting rid of my
mother's stuff when she passed away a
2009 that started this whole journey I
went down to to sort of go through her
stuff and I found all this these
sentimental items for boxes of my old
elementary school paper were big antique
furniture and paintings and all this
stuff and I learned some important
lessons there but some of the most
important ones I learned was first off
our memories aren't in our things our
memories are inside us and they always
will be you see we hold on the things
thinking that we can access the memories
in them but the memories are inside us
and so sometimes the things can trigger
memories and so what I did is I took
photos of a lot of my mom's old
furniture and things I was just going to
put in storage anyway I wasn't going to
get any true value from it but by
letting go I was able to add value to
other people's lives and then you know
what I went back to Ohio she was down in
Florida at the time I went back to Ohio
with just a few sentimental items and I
get far more value from the few things I
held on to if I didn't just have a
handful of things you know a few box of
photographs an old painting a few
doilies from her doily collection they
just a few things then if I were to
water those things down with dozens or
hundreds of sentimental items that were
stored in a storage locker just in case
those are the three most dangerous words
in the English language
just in case when we use those three
words to justify everything that we hold
onto so being willing to let go means
you're not willing to let go of the
memories you're willing to add value to
other people's lives who can actually
enjoy those things if you're not getting
immense value from them anymore someone
talked about trophies and what you do
with your kids clippings you know those
are things that you're probably holding
on to because you want your kids to
remember that you know I would ask your
kids what do they really want to hold on
to I don't know if your kids are still
in school and living with you or if
they're out of the house but if they're
out of the house which is what I'm
assuming here
I would ask them like hey do you want
any of this stuff because I don't want
to hold on to it anymore not that you
want to get rid of those memories but
certainly if you're feeling a lot of
weight from all that clutter then yeah
ask them if they want to hold on to it
and maybe look ups and that's what my
mom did she gave me like a bunch of
stuff and I literally just I have like a
box full of pictures and everything else
she gave me I just threw out so I
certainly know there another angle too
is if you're holding on to it for your
kids ask them if they even want that
stuff how do minimalist keep up with
technology I would encourage you go back
and listen to the second episode of our
podcast the minimalist podcast it's all
about technology ultimately what I would
say is we asked this question with our
stuff and then it bleeds over into
technology and others of our life as
well does this thing add value to my
life or just does this add value to my
life there's nothing wrong with with
technology although it has created some
problems and it's a bit quixotic to
think that we can also solve those
problems with more technology and so
what we do sometimes is we temporarily
deprive ourselves of technology so we
can see how we'll see what's truly
adding value to our lives so I would
encourage you to check out that that
podcast you just go to the minimalists
comm slash zero zero
- that's episode 2 and a couple essays
for you I wrote an essay called most
emergencies aren't if you just go to the
minimalists comm slash emergencies and
then also a minimalist approach to
technology that's the minimalists comm
slash technology you'll find a bunch of
ways that we approach technology and use
it more deliberately in our lives the
metaphor there is that that technology
can be like a chainsaw or a paint can so
I'll let you figure out what that means
by by reading the essay someone asked
about if they're an IT professional how
can they be a minimalist and still keep
up with the technology I'm going to go
back to what I've said probably three
times during this this spree part this
periscope is but minimalism there is not
one particular set of rules if you're an
IT professional and it's part of your
job and you've got to keep up with that
stuff well then I guess that's what
you're passionate about and that's what
you have to keep up with
you know that's not what JA sure I do i
buy guy my phone is you know couple
generations old certainly every time a
new phone comes out someone asked about
do we still struggle with anything yeah
certainly when a new phone comes out
when that iPhone six came out I'm like
oh man iPhone six that's cool it's it's
a bigger screen and and man my contracts
up but I could probably afford that now
and I'm now a my just upgrade and I look
into what it does and for me it didn't
do anything extra than what my phone
does now so I decided not to get it that
was probably someone on here who could
be like iPhone 6 is awesome because it
does XYZ better camera whatever else but
at the end of the day that stuff wasn't
going to add value to my life so I
didn't upgrade yeah and someone just
asked do you guys own your homes or do
you rent them we both rent but what I'll
tell you is the reason that I rent is
because I don't want to go into debt I
can't afford to pay cash for a home
right now and I put my personal belief
after being in massive amounts of debt I
used to make great money I had a high
six-figure income but I had massive
amounts of debt I had I spent more money
than I made even though I was making
good money I spent even better money and
that equation just does not work and so
I rent now because I believe that there
is no such thing as good debt I'm going
to repeat that in all caps flat locks
here there is no such thing as good dead
now some of you would say but a
mortgages it is an investment well first
off purchase a house is not an
investment most economists are going to
tell you purchasing a house is not
investment but I'll say that there's
nothing wrong with purchasing a house it
is a purchase not investment and so you
can own a home and still feel great
about it
if I were absolutely pinned against wall
I had to get a mortgage on make sure I
got a mortgage that wasn't longer than a
seven year fixed mortgage and for
something that can afford there are only
two countries on earth that have a
30-year fixed mortgage US and Denmark
and that is
in no one else this whole idea of having
a house and paying for for the rest of
your life
that is a new concept so I just decided
to rent right now and then I save money
and if one day I do want to purchase a
house and you can actually see this with
my retirement plan at the minimalists
comm slash retirement you can find
exactly how I'm saving money for the
future a part of that is owning a home
and being able to either pay for that
outright or having such a significant
down payment that I don't have to worry
about being trapped by debt and being
overwhelmed by debt there's no such
thing as good debt now there's better
debt than other debts I'd rather have a
mortgage than a payday loan at the
corner liquor store but it doesn't mean
other one of them are good if there's a
such thing as good debt then you would
be trying to get more and more and more
good debt right no some that's better
than others though yeah someone says I
hate debt bla yeah me too I spent the
first 31 years of my life in some form
of debt I wrote about that in our book
everything that remains about getting
out of debt and finally breaking that
cycle you can read neck served at the
minimalists com slash debt there's an
essay there about debt free yes I saw
two questions what about tiny houses
yeah I mean tiny houses are are awesome
if that's if that's what someone is into
I mean I don't want to tell you I'm
Josh's internat on you know but it's
certainly you know I'm open to doing
that later in life if that's what suits
me but yeah right now I mean I'm not
heading even close down down that path
but I think it is an awesome solution
for for a lot of people I mean tiny
homes we have an interview with Tami
strugle in her tiny home and literally
it is the most beautiful home I have
ever been in it's also the smallest home
I've ever been in but it was done so
deliberately and it was done so well
that it didn't really feel like I was in
a tiny home so yeah those are certainly
great solutions someone asked about how
we contribute to society oh great
question yet we've done a lot we've
raised money to build schools good yeah
I mean
we believe that the the me of life is
growth and contribution you know giving
is is living and and so we have found
ways to contribute beyond ourselves in a
meaningful way I think the biggest way
that we contribute is with our work now
whether it's our blog or books or
podcasts being able to give that to the
world but we try to do a bunch of other
philanthropic things as well in fact
2015 last year it was a year of
contribution for us we built wells in
Malawi so to clean water wells providing
water to people who would otherwise die
because they didn't have access to clean
water
what a terrible problem that is in
certain parts of the world where people
didn't have access to water we we were
able to thanks to our readers as well
and people helping us contribute we were
able to fund our ability in school and
in Laos and Ryan actually just attended
the grand opening ceremony for that it
was it was amazing with you being able
to contribute to all all elementary
school kids I could literally win the
one the one billion dollar jackpot and
that would not make me feel as good as
when I was there with with those kids
opening up that school giving is living
absolutely and we do as much of it as we
can and then we get the orphanage right
now yeah well even before that we funded
a high school and in Uganda for a year
because there was an opportunity to do
that you know with with about $15,000
we're able to fund an entire high school
and that's quite often the reason we we
go to other parts of the world when we
can to contribute because it isn't just
about focusing locally it's great if we
can and we do a lot of stuff locally
whether it's with homeless shelters or
food banks or Habitat for Humanity those
are all ways to contribute but $15,000
in the United States will fund about one
student for a year and in some cities
not even one student but if we could
fund an entire high school and set up
special programs to help the students
fund themselves in the future in Uganda
so it was self-sustaining in a way and
then right now we have we're building an
orphanage a family-style orphanage it's
a new concept with our friends over at
the hope effect and you can still
contribute that to that if you like till
the end of this month Ryan gave his bird
they toward the end of last year his
34th birthday instead of getting
birthday gifts he was asking for people
to help us build this orphanage and you
can still contribute to that in fact
that's why we're going to st. Petersburg
later this month to have three
caffeinated days with the minimalist
it's a charity event all money and tips
all profits raised will be used to to
fund this orphanage if you want to help
it's the minimalists comm slash hope
it's funny when I thought about vacation
before this I would always think of
myself oh where would I where's my dream
vacation Paris Rome Australia and after
visiting a third-world country that's
where my mind's at now what other
third-world countries can I visit and
actually get a real taste of what life
is like I'm Tony if you need a change in
perspective if you need goat I mean go
to Mexico there's a there's a Latin
third rule places a lot of places down
there that that will give you the same
feeling but but yeah third world
countries is certainly a great
perspective to have there's no doubt
about that
someone said do you think it's advisable
to live in a place that is not that
expensive yeah I mean it's funny I love
the city of San Francisco I know we're
sort of location independent now and
which is a weird term but we've heard we
moved out to Montana it's actually
slightly more expensive than Dayton Ohio
which is where we're from in terms of
the housing prices but the cost of
living otherwise is relatively low in
Montana and and I looked at San
Fransisco when we were first going
around I'm like what the apartment I had
in Dayton Ohio was five hundred and
seventy-five dollars a month in San
Francisco the same apartment in the city
was four thousand dollars a month and
I'm like well I don't think that's for
me
I can't afford that and so yeah it's
advisable to pare down your bills your
expenses so you're not tied to a
particular lifestyle that forces you to
do things that are outside your values
is there anything you know it doesn't go
with your values that you struggle with
quitting doing yeah I think you asked
that question before I was talking about
like upgrading my phone is there
anything that you struggle was no I mean
no because I've aligned my values with
my
actions if I struggle with anything it's
things that are our passive distraction
right and and so it whether it's you
know incessantly scrolling through
instant Instagram or watching TV it's
reason I'll have a TV right now or doing
things that are just passive getting
stuck in that Bermuda Triangle it's the
reason I don't have internet at home and
you can read about that experience I do
a bunch of experiment to get rid of
internet at home for a month or
something I did and it was the most
productive month of my life so you can
go to the minimalists comm slash
internet and I wrote it all about that
that whole experience I've gotten rid of
my TV and cell phone and other things
for periods of time and you can read
about those experiments at our website
as well yes um never struggled with
addiction
yes I'm addicted to so much yeah I was
well actually it's funny cuz there was a
question someone asked before about
those minimalism help with depression or
anxiety and what I'll tell you is that I
was at a certain point in my life where
I was so anxious and so stressed out
that I pacified myself with a lot of
drugs and alcohol and I was very very
very hooked
especially on drugs and what I can tell
you is that when I started to simplify
my life when I started to make more
deliberate decisions when I started to
take an inventory not just of my stuff
but of the people I was hanging around
the way I was spending my time the way I
was using my resources once I was able
to get the clutter out of the way
to make room for all was truly important
it certainly did help me to focus on
getting over that addiction and I went
got help and I don't want to underplay
that at all because anyone who's
addicted to anything is so so addiction
is it is I would not wish the pain that
I went through on my worst enemy it was
one of the hardest things I've ever had
to do in my life um but I can certainly
tell you that minimalism definitely
helped me to get the clutter out of the
way to make it so I wasn't so stressed
out I did have less stress I did have
not just less but a lot less stress I
had a lot less anxiety once I got rid of
all that looming debt once I started to
get a grip on
real life once I started to not have to
work 60 70 80 hours a week all of that
certainly did help with with me having
less stress less anxiety and ultimately
overcoming that addiction would you say
that that maybe surround yourself with
different people who are a better
influence oh that process yeah I mean
that's it's it's funny because people
several times I've asked about you know
how to get rid of friends or whatever
else and and yeah I ultimately had to go
to my friends and say hey you know how I
usually meet you
here on you know Tuesdays Wednesdays and
Thursday nights for happy hour and we
sit here and we drink ourselves silly
and then we go do a bunch of drugs I'm
not going to be hanging out with you
anymore because if I was to put myself
in that situation I would probably go
right back to it and when I think about
the connection that I had with the
particular person in mind that I'm
thinking about right now that's the only
Connection we had like if we were sober
hanging out with each other it would
have been it would have been horrible
and the only thing I would add to that
is our material possessions our physical
manifestation of what's going on inside
minimalism starts with the stuff but
once we get that excess out of the way
we start clearing that we're able to
start dealing with what's going on
inside so if that's anxiety if it's
depression if it's overwhelmed if it's
stressed if it's discontent if it's
worried we're able to start dealing with
those emotions and it first kind of ugly
because we actually have to deal with it
right and so it's not fun at first but
it's worth it
because it's about living a meaningful
life not a perfect life our lives
certainly aren't perfect but they're
much better
they're much simpler and they're much
more meaningful than what they were in
the past someone asked about do we
meditate yeah I meditate for five
minutes a day sometimes 10 I use a great
app called the headspace app that
encouraged me to do it for 10 to 20 and
we interviewed several amazing
meditators for our documentary
minimalism a documentary about the
important things that comes out in
theatres this may if you want to check
out a great book about meditation for
regular people so it's not all
we and spiritual and and all those other
things but for regular guys and gals you
know I would check out Dan Harris's book
called 10% happier we did an interview
with him on our website the minimalists
column slash Dan check that out
was I skeptical skeptical I first saw
Josh starting to minimize I will say I
didn't know what was going on because he
never really came out and said oh whoa
I'm practicing this thing called
minimalism it took me a few months of
watching him get happier get less stress
is is really when I wanted to go to him
and ask him like you know why the hell
are you so happy but I will tell you the
first memory I have of realizing
something different was going on is when
him and his wife split up he moved into
his own apartment and of course you know
he helps me cause me to help him move we
always joked around like this was like
season five of Ryan and Josh move heavy
things because like I'm like his go-to
guy when he needs heavy things move um
but uh but yeah it was over season five
of that and we were moving into his new
apartment and he didn't have a lot of
stuff and I was like oh like oh he must
be he must be going and getting some
more stuff later that he's gonna help me
move in and then I remember going to his
home you know two or three weeks later
there was nothing new there and I
remember thinking there's not TV like in
a TV stand or not a TV stand but a TV
mount that came with like the apartment
that was on the wall but no TV on and I
kept asking I'm like dude are you gonna
get a TV when are you getting it get a
TV it wasn't wrong with you right and he
never came out and said no I'm a
minimalist I'm not good at TV he just
simply said like no man like I'm trying
to do things a little bit differently
and I'm not quite sure if I'm gonna get
a TV or not and maybe I will maybe I
won't but right now TV isn't necessary
for me so I'm not going to get it so so
yeah I don't wanna say I was skeptical
as much it's just kind of confused as to
why Josh was all of a sudden shooing
some of these these things I will tell
you I was asked by some of our
counterparts
if Josh was depressed or if he was going
to kill himself because that's like the
first sign of what someone's gonna kill
themselves when they give every message
yeah it's so sad
that we've turned consumerism into a
sign that you're not suicidal when in
essence you're suicidal so you go buy a
lot of stuff or you're reaching the
suicidal soon as suicidal a depressed
point so you're trying to fill this void
with stuff more stuff and more stuff
speaking of stuff someone said do you
still read paper books and and my answer
to that is yeah I still read paper books
I go to library all the time and I'll
check out books there or I'll buy
physical paper books I prefer reading on
the Kindle and there's a few reasons for
that one is I used to own 2,000 books
you can read about my experience of
getting rid of 2,000 books and actually
reading more if you go to the
minimalists comm slash reading I had so
many books because I thought it made me
look smart you come over to my house I
look at all these books I might read one
day and some distant hypothetical
non-existent future but the only books I
tend to hold on to now are reference
books so I have a small very well
curated collection because I've learned
that the value is in the words not the
physical artifact itself and plus with
the Kindle I know if you ever tried to
move 2,000 books but I tried to and I
threw out my back I have a terrible back
already
it's much easier to move 2,000 books if
they're stored on a Kindle as opposed to
a entire library of books and by the way
if you support us by it by by getting
any of our books there's a few ways you
can do that you can do the e-book you
can also go to your local library and
check it out if they don't have it they
can usually order it and you don't have
to pay any money for it that way and so
we're not out here trying to hock a
bunch of books no but what we're trying
to do is add value to your life and I
know that a lot of books have changed my
life and thankfully we've been able to
write some books that have changed other
people's lives as well if you buy a
paper copy of our book minimize it
afterwards yeah fine someone else who
can get value from it and be willing to
let it go someone asked me what do I
think about alcohol or I don't know if
they're asking us in general I drink
still I don't drink to get drunk I will
talk I will go on hiatuses where if I do
feel like it's becoming a crutch or
something that I'm looking on as a
pacifier
then you know I will totally do a ghost
over October in May if I have to my
girlfriend and I what we do a really
good job of kind of keeping each other
and check with like the moderation and
like I said if it starts to get to a
point where we're like maybe we should
be a little bit without drinking that's
what we do
but I certainly don't rely on it as a
crunch anymore josh is a raging
alcoholic oh I've never I've never drunk
in my life and the reason that I don't
is my mother had really really bad
problems with alcoholism and I realized
that I am prone to impulsive compulsive
behaviors and I certainly have an
addictive personality and so I prefer to
be addicted to something that allows me
to still be a functioning member of of
society like writing so that's that's my
addiction yeah I know we did not be a
cliche writer if you wasted a drunk yeah
what do you like we'll never see me
again right no I'll tell you I've known
Josh since we were fat little fifth
graders I've never seen him ticket sip
of alcohol or hit of a cigarette or
anything
go straight edge guy explains a lot
actually the last question here was uh
did did minimalism change or social
media participation and so yeah we use a
bunch of different platforms now and we
talked about this on the technology
episode of the minimalists podcast you
can go back and listen to that as number
two but I'll sum it up like this is yeah
whenever we're using something whether
it's Pinterest or Facebook or Twitter or
Instagram we're constantly asking this
question is this going to add value to
the world you'll never see us pose a
picture picture of our breakfast or of
cats or whatever because we don't think
that serves the greater good necessarily
we're not judging other people who do
but we prefer to only use it in a way
that contributes to the world beyond us
Josh do you remember a time when we used
to actually have to take like a regular
film picture of our food you'd like go
to light and you like just
a wind-up camera right exactly then you
have to go get that developed and then I
had good luck Walgreens
right right or where we lived was four
seasons video remember that right right
and then we would go to each other's
house and we would show each other
pictures of food no we never did that no
one ever did that
well everyone thank you for your time
today we really appreciate it we hope to
see you next Tuesday in the meantime you
can interact with us on social media on
facebook.com slash the minimalists
twitter we're at the minimus Instagram
at the minimalist and if we leave you
with just one bit of advice one message
from this whole broadcast we hope it's
this love people and use things because
the opposite never works see you guys
have a go on thanks for your time
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your greed oh I bet that you'll
be fine
without every little thing that you got
ahead every little thing that you guys
you gotta reach for you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without me
so share your tea